oh my god
did you see that welcome
to scotland the home of maltscotch
kilts and sea monsters
it's time to get up close and personal
with the loch ness monster
affectionately known as nessie
what species is she
what does she eat and
how would life change if we found her
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the loch ness monster were real
the loch ness monster is said to be a
giant
marine creature residing in loch ness
scotland
reports of nessie go all the way back to
565
ce but she became an international
sensation
in 1934 when physician robert kenneth
wilson
shot this iconic photo
reported to be about two and a half
meters long
nessie is said to resemble a dragon or
prehistoric monster rumors even suggest
that she's a plesiosaur a marine reptile
that went extinct around
65 and a half million years ago
so if nessie really is
swimming around the lock what kind of
animal would we be dealing with
well our bet isn't on some sort of
prehistoric creature but
a giant eel and if
nessie is a sort of giant eel
chances are she would be carnivorous
this means she would consume the fish
native to the lake and
any small invertebrates she could get
nessie could chow down on pike trout
sticklebacks minnows char and other
creatures native to the lake
maybe if she were big enough she would
feed on some
unlucky deer or otters that took a dip
in the lake
but enough about the lock dwellers how
would the discovery of the loch ness
monster
change human lives i mean how would we
even go about dealing with something
like that
well we don't have to guess because the
scottish government has
an official plan in place in 2001
the scottish national heritage agency
now called
nature scott prepared a code of practice
if
anyone were to find the creature
specifically
the document says that a dna sample
would be taken from the monster
to identify her once and for all oh no
are they going to experiment on poor
nessie
thankfully no the code states that after
taking the dna sample nessie
will be released back into the lock to
sweeten the deal even more the document
also describes that the species monster
or not
would need to be protected from harm
this is crucial because
once it's confirmed that the loch ness
monster exists
curious searchers would be joined by
hunters and poachers
we can only imagine what a taxidermied
nessie would go for on the black market
so how would a protected nessie
repay the people of scotland well
the loch ness monster would undoubtedly
become something of a golden goose
the loch ness monster contributes almost
41 million british pounds to the
scottish economy every year
if you could see the monster we could
expect that figure to skyrocket
the tourist industry in loch ness would
change dramatically
maybe there would be loch ness monster
tours just like
whale watching tours life's been pretty
good since i opened up my hotel in loch
ness
people come from all over the world to
see the monster right from the balconies
trouble is nessie's a bit shy and some
days she doesn't show up
so to avoid taking any chances i invest
my money in gold
gold can act as a hedge against
inflation
deflation and in this case the stage
fright of a giant sea monster
it's literally the gold standard for
value and can provide financial
stability during these uncertain times
just head on over to the sponsor of this
video jmbullion.com
j m bullion is an easy to use discreet
accredited physical precious metals
retailer
with over four billion dollars in
revenue and over two million orders
shipped
jm bullion is one of the largest most
respected
online physical dealers of gold and
silver in the world
get in touch with jmbullion.com today
even without evidence the legend of
nessie brings the tourists in
in droves we are going to see
lock ness i've done research and i know
where to look for you sucka
they support hotels souvenir shops and
the local economy as a whole with a real
nessie in the lock
the economy would boom the downside of
that is
all that attention may overwhelm the
area and
more importantly it might overwhelm
nessie's ecosystem
it's possible that the area would need
to be restricted to a certain number of
people at a time
sort of like a safari with humans not
interacting or disturbing the animal
so is it possible that nessie may
really be out there
[Music]
maybe there's always a chance of
discovering
a new species i mean there was a time
when people thought
the platypus and komodo dragon were the
stuff of legend
the good news is if nessie is out there
scotland has her back but
this has us thinking if nessie is real
that means some other big contenders are
too
maybe it's time to look for the world's
hide and seek champion
what if bigfoot was real
well obviously that's a story
for another what if
[Music]